In 1991, Mount Pinatubo
in the Philippines erupted
becoming the second largest volcanic eruption
of the 20th century.
Its ash plume shot up
past the atmosphere
and into the stratosphere
dispersing a layer of aerosol particles
around the whole world.
Those particles formed
a sort of solar umbrella
that reflected sunlight
away from the earth
caused global temperatures to drop
by about half a degree Celsius
for almost two years.
It's not the first massive
volcanic eruption
to cool global temperatures.
El Chichón volcano
lowered temperatures by
a similar amount in 1982
as did other major eruptions
over the past century.
Today, scientists have been exploring
whether we could replicate
this phenomenon
to fight global warming.
Using a technology called
solar geoengineering.
Supporters say it's a tool
we need to seriously explore
as climate change worsens.
Understanding more about these things
that could potentially
reduce suffering.
That's worth a lot.
But critics believe the technology's risks
outweigh its rewards
and shouldn't be a response
to fighting global warming.
Sometimes more technology
is not always better.
There are some things that
have been invented
that a lot of people would wish
had never been invented.
So which one is it?
To understand the benefits
and risks of solar geoengineering,
I spoke to several scientists,
lawyers, indigenous leaders
with strong opinions on both sides.
With stakes as high as the survival
of the human race on Earth...
should we be exploring
solar geoengineering?
There's one thing scientists
all agree on:
Solar geoengineering could
cool down the planet.
Reflecting sunlight away
from the earth
stops heat from getting trapped
in our atmosphere.
We could do that by injecting aerosols
into the stratosphere
like volcanoes can do.
That's the most commonly
researched approach.
Some scientists are also looking into
brightening marine clouds
so they're better at reflecting
the sun.
And other potential methods
include reflective shields
in outer space.
These initiatives are still in different stages
of the research phase
but in order for us to deploy
these technologies
and get large scale cooling effects,
we'd need to interfere
with our complex climate
on a massive scale.
One of the main reasons
some scientists
support solar geoengineering
is that we're currently on
a pretty dire path.
Our emissions, mainly carbon dioxide,
keep rising.
There's really no question
we must cut emissions in the long run.
But even if you cut emissions
to zero tomorrow...
that does not eliminate climate risk.
It just means you stop the climate risk
getting worse
because the climate risk comes from
accumulated emissions.
That's University of Chicago
professor David Keith.
He explained to me that
unless we think beyond
emission reduction
the climate change impacts
we're already experiencing
will continue to worsen.
A recent study showed that
extreme weather
accounted for nearly 10%
of all global deaths
and shows an increase
in heat related ones.
To mitigate those effects
supporters argue that we need
to explore climate processes
use computer modeling,
and develop technology
to figure out if and maybe how
this technology
could safely be deployed globally
along with other solutions.
The thing is, messing with
our global climate
is very complicated.
The whole climate system
is wired together.
People could, technologically speaking,
create major...
unpredictable changes in the way
the climate system responds.
Oxford Professor Raymond Pierre Humbert
is referencing
one of the big concerns
about solar geoengineering.
Adding new elements into
our atmosphere or stratosphere
will change precipitation patterns
across the world...
potentially worsening the extreme weather
we're already experiencing
due to climate change.
Nearly everyone agrees
on these risks.
—And...
—You can't actually answer
the most significant questions about
the climate system response.
Short of a full scale deployment.
A full scale deployment
would require unprecedented
global cooperation
not just in terms of scale, but
in terms of time.
But the carbon dioxide we have emitted
since the industrial revolution
and we emit today will continue
to have a warming effect
on climate for thousands of years
from now
even if we stop emitting.
But in contrast, the solar geoengineering
techniques proposed
have a very short lifetime in the atmosphere.
To create a continued cooling effect
we would need to deploy them
constantly for centuries.
That means that you're committed
to having institutions and treaties
that can be adhered to
for thousands of years.
And that's a really unprecedented
sort of burden to put on
future humanity.
If there an international disagreement
war, global depression,
or something that forces
a sudden termination of
solar geoengineering...
then the world gets hit
with this rapid warming.
That rapid warming is called
termination shock.
And the risk of it happening
is one of the big reasons critics think
solar geoengineering is ungovernable
and unsustainable.
And so far, we have a pretty poor record
of figuring out how to move
things forward.
In 2021, Sweden rejected a pioneering project
to test solar geoengineering
technology.
Environmental and indigenous groups
issued a letter
highlighting “the potential for creating
drastically uneven, unpredictable changes
on climate
weather and biodiversity.”
and “geopolitical tensions
it might awaken”.
It would cause great changes...
to our environment and
to our ecosystem
and those precious ecosystems
that we are...
advocating so hard for.
To protect and safeguard
and secure
and strengthen.
Opposition like this is one reason
that most solar geoengineering research
is taking place in labs with
models and simulations.
Turning the debate about
solar geoengineering
into one about how far we should take
the research.
In January of 2022
400 scientists issued a letter calling for
a non-use agreement on solar geoengineering.
It included five core commitments,
among them
no outdoor experiments,
no public funding
and no support from
international institutions.
Professor Pierre Humbert was one of the scientists
who signed it.
He explained that the signatories
are okay with low risk research.
So research that's on fundamental
climate processes
that doesn't develop the technology
that leads to deployment
that can provide useful information.
Computer simulations and modeling
are midway through the spectrum.
Critics of solar geoengineering worry that
the more modeling we do
the closer we'll get to full scale deployment.
But they acknowledge that
some simulations are useful
and a key part of overall science
we can't eliminate.
We are pretty clear on the idea
that research that was essentially
technology development
that would lead to deployment
was something
that the signatories are opposed to.
Lili Fuhr, who works at the Center
for Intenational Environmental Law
told me something similar.
Soon as we let the genie out of the bottle...
and if we not only just
theoretically research
but completely develop
a certain technology...
it will most certainly get used.
We've seen that with other technologies as well.
About a year later,
in February of 2023
110 scientists, including Keith,
issued a letter in support of
more research into solar geoengineering.
They want a robust, international
scientific assessment
that includes experiments that could
potentially advanced technology...
but stated that “while we fully support
the research
this does not mean we support the use
of solar geoengineering tech.”
We can't bind the hands of the future
and force them
never to use these technologies.
So if we make a collective decision now
not to do serious research that
doesn't prevent people
employing this technology in the future.
It just means they will deploy them
with less knowledge.
I asked Sarah Doherty, who studies
maring cloud brightening
at the University of Washington
about research like this.
Doing the research right now
really is important...
and it's important to making...
equitable decisions
down the road.
Because the cat's out of the bag.
People know these options exist.
Some people think we should
be going out
and doing them right now.
So that tells you how likely it is people
20 years from now
are going to be saying,
“Let's go do this.”
A big concern both sides agree on
is the negative impact
solar geoengineering could have
on decarbonization efforts...
and that the tech might act
as an excuse for
oil and gas companies to keep
selling fossil fuels.
To unleash the technology of
solar geoengineering on the world...
at a time when we've just barely
started to get people interested
in doing the hard work
of decarbonization...
that will just inevitably
increase the pressure
to just take business as usual.
I absolutely agree that a risk
around these technologies...
is that they will be exploited
by people who want to
preserve emissions.
But agreeing on the issue
doesn't mean agreeing
on the path forward.
That is a political concern.
In my view, it is not
an ethical basis
for restricting research
on technologies
that are potentially risk reducing.
So far, Mexico is the only country
that's banned solar geoengineering experiments.
While the US is currently developing
a solar geoengineering research plan.
World organizations focused on climate
are now starting to make
assessments and recommendations.
I can't tell you which one
is exactly right.
What I can tell you is that
each and every single person
I spoke to
on either side of the issue cares deeply
about our future on this planet.
And maybe that tension between them
is actually a good thing...
because while it doesn't make
our path forward clear...
it can make us more thoughtful
and rigourous
about how to solve this giant mess
we are currently in.